welcome everyone
thank you for joining us for today's
presentation titled broaden your
applications with magnetic bead
conjugation
it's my pleasure to introduce to you tom
lyons custom projects leader genomics
and diagnostic solutions sativa
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
now if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them in the q a box
our speaker will address your questions
following the end of the presentation
so please join me in welcoming tom lyons
i will now turn the presentation over to
him welcome tom
hi uh thank you very much for that
introduction um
this is a presentation on the
application or the use of magnetic beads
um in your
own applications in your laboratories
and specifically the conjugation onto
those magnetic beads
so i'll skip right ahead from the first
slide and just go into a little bit on
the agenda and what to expect
so
initially we wanted to cover in this
presentation was the sativa organization
a little bit and also the site where we
manufacture our magnetic beads which is
cardiff in the uk
um and being a centre of excellence uh
for sativa it's one we're very proud of
so we just wanted to highlight um a bit
about the team there and just sort of
show off to you guys
then
just in case we've got any people here
or any scientists here who haven't heard
of the use of magnetic particles
we're going to highlight a little bit
about paramagnetic properties and some
of the particles that we have in our
portfolio
after that we are going to look at the
applications of magnetic beads
specifically around our portfolio um and
what we hope you guys are uh doing in
your laboratories and seeing how
these might give you some ideas for some
further experiments
additionally we're going to cover the
conjugation of our magnetic particles
and a little bit of focus on some
do's and don'ts
as well as some ideas for conjugation
and finally we were going to cover the
custom services team customized
solutions team uh which i'm part of and
we we're going to talk about we're going
to i'm going to talk about sorry
how
this team based in cardiff where we
manufacture the beads can help you
further the your
applications and get you that one step
closer to being able to use paramagnetic
beads for you for your desired technique
so a little introduction slide and we'll
just go into the kardash site
so the main art center which as i said
is based in cardiff in the uk has been
manufacturing biopharma particle or
biopharma
materials for the sector for the past 40
years
it supplies to a global customer base
with over two and a half thousand
customers in the research and diagnostic
market
each year there are 90 000 sales
of orders which are shipped to customers
each year and as i say they're across
the globe
and on-site in cardiff there's a team of
over 200 people who are manufacturing
over 1500 products for you guys to
purchase so it's a it's quite a big
skype and it's quite a busy site
the team which i'm part of is the
genomics and diagnostics team sorry it's
the genomics and diagnostics business
and with a custom customized team who
are based within that group
there's a
seven scientists in our team who are all
dedicated to the custom projects
we
work from university startups all the
way through to large biopharma
corporations
and we approach each custom product a
custom opportunity
with the same dedication and the same
intention of output for you guys to get
a product or a custom material specific
for your application
we can make
projects
which go from very small proof of
principle scale all the way up to full
scale manufacturing runs and that
depending on what application that is
will depend on what we make
and
as of this year which has been a busy
year i think for all of us in this
sector
we've been working with more than 50
different organizations across the globe
to deliver custom products
so then i wanted to run on and describe
paramagnetic particles
so
in here we've got a couple of nice
videos which you can find on youtube
just to have a look at how the particles
look and how they handle inside a liquid
which can help people visualize things a
little bit but in principle um a
paramagnetic particle
is not like a magnet it doesn't
continually sit there and try and
attract itself to each other they're
paramagnetic in that they only show
magnetic properties when they are within
a magnetic field
so if you look at the slide on the left
where you see there's a mixture of a
solution with our paramagnetic beads
they will sit there and
be diffuse and and effectively uh become
a part of the solution
then when you apply a magnetic field
this can be simply one of our
bench magnets uh
which which we have um or or a simple
button magnet that some people use
the beads are attracted to that magnet
and they are attracted to themselves so
they will start to
agglutinate towards each other and will
all be drawn into what is described as a
pellet
where the magnetic field is the
strongest
what you can then do is when you have
this pellet at the side of the vessel
you can remove
any other liquid which you don't want or
maybe you want to keep and the beads
have removed something you don't want
and you can add another solution back in
and by then by releasing the magnetic
field in other words taking the vial
out of the um
the magnetic stand
the beads will go back into solution and
that's one of the the key properties of
these paramagnetic particles
part of the family of paramagnetic
particles that we have are the ceramic
beads
and these are around
one micron in diameter
it's a very um
mono dispersed size for them
they're super paramagnetic which means
they have a very strong magnetic prop
moment within a magnetic field and all
and and
simply zero magnetic properties when
there is no magnetic field
they have at this cauliflower like
surface which i'll describe on the next
slide just to help people visualize it
which is why they seem a little bit
rough on the on the surface
um
key points for these are they have
excellent colloidal stability so
they're very uh
very good in aqueous solutions they
don't like to uh
clump up then they they dispen disperse
very well
um
they have
almost no leaching properties of the
materials they're made of so they're
very clean to using diagnostic samples
and they're very easy to use but just
simple bench top magnets or as i said
button magnets can be used
so here we've got a tem of the surface
of our beads and as you can see it looks
very rough and ready and this this rough
surface this cauliflower like surface
helps um
some of the capture properties which are
quite unique to our beads and helps them
with the um
increased surface area that many people
comment on how our beads perform whether
that's with a custom liquid on the
surface of them or whether it's our
streptavidin beads which are part of our
catalogue
the ceramic product range is quite vast
um we we sell
um a large amount of them from different
with different functionalities on them
so i just wanted to give this slide for
any researchers who are here who are
curious about where you can use these
particles
in your
own applications so we cover the areas
of diagnostics genomics and proteomics
diagnostics in with just our core
particles of carboxyl
beads uh which are
the sort of the core particle we have
and these can be functions with uh
functionalized with oligos or
streptavidin
as well as we have a second family which
is the core bead with another layer of
magnetite added onto them so they are
they will move to the magnet even faster
than the standard bead
the genomics area we cover the um also
the oligobead and the car box will be
but also with an extra focus on
the streptavidin surface now whether
that's
streptavidin um
just on the bead but a further blocking
a chemical blocking of the gr of the
particles for a streptavidin blocked
bead
and finally look at the proteomics area
where mostly it's focused on the
streptavidin neutrophidine
binding but we also have some bulk
protein ag affinity beads as well
additionally to the uh ceramic family
there is the cyrosilmag family of
particles and we have two in our
catalogue as it stands a
700 nanometer and a 400 nanometer size
particle so these are our smallest
particles that we have in the catalog
um
they are they are part of a silica shell
um with magnetite inside the core of the
particles they are have a very narrow
size distribution so they're all very
similar in size um
and they move exceedingly fast to uh to
a magnet so they're they're probably are
the the most rapid um of the magnetic
particles or the paramagnetic particles
that we have part of the portfolio
and additionally there is another uh
paramagnetic part
um product
this is the magsephrose particles and
these are based on
an agarose
particle with a core of magnetite or
paramagnetic material in the middle of
the beads
these range of the size from 37 to 100
micrometer so there's still quite a
narrow size distribution but
specifically for the bulk purification
of um
of of samples um based on the agarose
sepharose um particle um
uh
sort of family of purifications
and a little bit more on how the
magcephros beads the ceramic beads and
the cirrus silmag beads those silica
particles uh which i talked about on
here
so as you can see there's many different
coatings for both the magsepheros and
the ceramic beads and the silica
particles we don't have any specific
functionalizations of them at the moment
it's just the silent surface
which is effectively a hydroxyl surface
on the bead
and so
depending on your application you're
welcome to talk to us about that if you
have any further questions you can see
where we can help guide you as to what
what type of bead might be most
appropriate for your application whether
that's nucleic acid purification or
protein purification
as well as
some of the handling
sort of
techniques you may want to have with
those particles
so further on from this we i wanted to
talk about uh applications for magnetic
particles to give you an idea if you
have current particles maybe they're
using um 96 well plates with some kind
of solid phase
um to
to
bind your sample out of a solution or
your analyte of interest
so i was going to go further into that
in the next couple of slides
but one thing
which is very
useful for all of these um materials is
that
whether whether it's the ceramic family
of beads or the magcepharos um
specifically you can the the
modification of the surface of the
particles is
key to how they will perform in your
application
so whether that needs to have um
an affinity label for um or a
complementary label for for a nucleic
acid binding
or maybe it's uh binding some kind of
probe onto the surface of of the of the
particle along with the magnetic bead to
detect um
to detect it further downstream
the these are all the many modifications
which we've had experience it with in
the custom team um as well as within the
broader portfolio that we're happy to
help with
specifically uh i wanted to talk about
uh the
binding of um a
molecular probe uh with our poly tea
bead
so
you as as we have part of our part of
our portfolio has the oligo dt magnetic
particles
and this will bind to a poly a um
molecule or
oligo
in your sample
what can further be done with that oligo
is it can you can then um
synthetically
turn that oligo into a poly a but then
with a specific sequence at the end of
the poly a to bind to a target of
interest and so by using the poly the
oligo dt bead
to bind your oligo sequence of interest
using the poly a affinity which is built
into the oligo gt the
poly a tail for want of a better word
you can then make many different um
detection
probes
within your part from the same particle
but with many different oligo sequences
using as i say that poly a affinity at
the end of them and so this is quite a
common technique for binding out targets
of interest in solutions or even binding
um rna
within solutions as well for further
downstream
applications
then another very common uh use of the
particles is for immunoassay um
be it diagnostics or immunopurification
and here
you will we you can bind a capture
antibody or a biotinylated capture
antibody depending on what your
tech how sensitive your technique is to
the biotin binding sometimes it can have
some
non-specific binding associated with it
and so you either couple the capture
anti anti-antibody directly onto the
surface of the bead or couple it with a
biotin
streptavidin conjugation so that using
the streptavidin beads in our portfolio
to bind a biotinylated capture antibody
this
is then able to uh that capture antibody
will then be able to have an affinity
for your analyte of interest
and
further downstream using a um
a detection antibody with some either
fluorophore
or some uh enzyme
to
create a signal depending on how much of
the detection antibody has been bound on
the surface of the
um beads
and we just wanted to highlight that to
that particular sort of antibody
affinity purification in the next slide
after this where we've
we've
we've got a little illustration of um
domain antibody expressed by e coli
and then using bag sepharose protein l
modified magsepheros
to
bind out the domain antibody from the um
expression of e coli
and specifically in the the illustration
i just want to cover
we show very high binding capacity and
also significant reductions in
endotoxicity or endotoxins
from the e coli expression
so a little bit of a description of what
we have here but if you look at the um
images in the bottom left we've used our
magseferose bound to protein l
then by adding the e coli
expression into a wave bag a cell wave
bag
mixing them together
we then place it onto a um
flat uh sorry a a wave platform
which is a series of magnets which then
binds out and then pulls out the protein
l
magsepheros with any of the toxins which
have been bound to it sorry with any of
the dab the domain antibody which has
been bound to it out of the solution
and so what we found in a very short
period of time as you can see from the
um
uh
graph on the right hand side
within a few minutes we've bound 90
of the domain antibody out of the
solution
and we're able to then wash the whole
solution
with um an aleutian uh buffer a very
simple one of uh citrate
and there's and we've done some further
uh
um
investigations to show that uh the
endotoxin reduction has endotoxicity has
been reduced sick by a number of logs
and the ehcp reduction as well by a
number of logs so
just just to highlight the use of beads
to
capture a material of interest
and to remove any contaminants you may
find in your assays or expressions so
this would be a bulk purification
example
so
with what we have from there are a
couple of examples of using magnetic
beads for uh specific applications
but obviously there's many many
applications and and what one thing
we're quite proud of with our um
ceramag and the cyrosil mag and the
magcephros technologies that they are
they are quite broad in their
capabilities um once they have been
modified
examples of modifications that we have
for our particles or modifications that
we can offer
um
we can offer a modification of the
concentration typically they're supplied
at one percent or five percent uh solid
content and we can describe the solid
content um to anyone if they'd like some
more information
um the formulation or the buffer that
they're supplied in
whether they would like to be conjugated
to a specific enzyme or antibody or
oligo or custom ligand
we
are happy to discuss and investigate
custom particles for your specific
applications be those modifications of
the size of the particles or some other
function
we have
used our particles for
freeze drying or lyophilization
of them and whether that be with a
custom function on them or whether that
be just the standard core particle
additionally as i said the cardiff site
is a large
site and a center of excellence that we
have within sativa and so modifications
of the pack sizes or um
number of
uh number of materials or number of
products you'd like to receive per per
delivery
is also something which we we look into
so when we talk about customization not
simply the um
modification of the particle uh for a uh
like say a specific antibody we also
look into
optimizing that particle for your
workflow
typically the beads that we find
ourselves modifying are the ceramic
beads
those are produced in cardiff
of those
those are also produced in cardiff
and
when we modify them we modify them from
two of their particular functional
moieties
whether that be the carboxyl modified
beads or whether that be from the amine
blocked magnetic beads
specifically the carboxyl modified beads
we will use for capturing nucleic acids
just purely onto the surface or whether
that's modifying them to bind on say the
an oligodt functionality or some other
oligo functionality
and they can also be used for
conjugating to
proteins or
other
molecules of interest which have an
available primary amine group on the
surface
and we also offer that in a high-speed
version as well so you like i said
earlier we load on a second layer of
magnetite in order to move allow them a
particle to be drawn to a magnet that
much quicker
additionally to the carboxyl modified
particles
we have a further amine blocked particle
amine block specifically
so this now has a chemical blocking
functionality on the surface of the bead
this isn't a protein blocking um and the
primary
surface moiety on the front of the
surface of the bead is the aiming group
similar conjugation strategies can be
used um typically con carboxyl aiming
conjugations are used quite readily
throughout this sector
um but also uh it will change the
surface charge of the bead as well so
you don't get quite get the same binding
of nucleic acids to the surface of the
beads as you can with the carboxyl beats
for affinity purification dna
purification
and then i just wanted to have a little
talk about if you guys uh
working
with our particles
just a few
common
challenges to make when you are using um
ceramic particles or typically any
magnetic paramagnetic particles um our
beads are supplied in a 0.05 sodium
azide preservative um
if you're doing conjugations yourselves
this will interfere with your
conjugations or maybe also interfere
with your application so we recommend
washing the beads three times or more in
your buffer of choice be that
conjugation buffer or storage buffer
and when i mean by washing um
effectively it's a drawing down of the
bead onto a magnet removing the
supernatant
allowing the beads to reconstitute into
your buffer of choice and repeating that
three times it takes a few minutes
but can really help
with some troubleshooting further
downstream
additionally uh a large number of
antibodies which we'll buy buy from
common suppliers are supplied in a high
glyceral concentration buffer for their
stability um
in frozen conditions
which will enable them not to freeze
um when doing
conjugations for um or covalent
conjugations with our carboxyl beads
that will need to be removed so whether
that needs to be removed by a dialysis
or some kind of um
buffer exchange technique um as the
glycerol will will interfere with your
conjugation methods
what
what we do find
for the ceramic bees specifically
they're very soluble in waters or and
then many aqueous
solutions
um
but we do find that they can stick uh to
the side of some plasticware um not none
of the plasticware that we use in-house
in sativa and that's one of the
learnings that we have inside the
cardiff center and we're happy to share
whatever knowledge we have with with
yourselves
but we do recommend if you are doing
your own conjugations and you intend to
store them in an aqueous buffer at the
end just typically add a small amount of
surfactant to those buffers which can
really help stabilize the solution but
also encourage it not to stick to the
surface of any plastic where you may be
using
additionally uh it's worth highlighting
the ceramic beads are very stable in a
wide wide range of ph of buffers
so you can go from very low to very high
ph's with the same beads and there's no
further modification that you need to
look out for or risk of the particles um
suffering um throughout that
do be aware that if you have bound a
protein onto the surface of these
particles that um
large changes in ph can be detrimental
to the protein so you you need to
understand your uh your application as
well there
so
we've got the last section here um i've
talked a little bit about um the
portfolio of where we make the particles
um a little bit about um some
applications for our particles and then
further modifications of them um that
you may want to consider
for your own application
specifically in cardiff is the
customized solutions team which again is
what i'm part of
and we offer
a series of
capabilities
around the genomics and diagnostics
portfolio
whether that be stabilizing of your
biological material or your sample or
even your say master mix
for lyo stable
whether that's to scale up your
application into a kit or
into uh or for further use downstream as
as your business grows
so we can do formulations inside the
manufacturing facility
um
whether you would like specific
conjugations of the particles
whether that's a specific oligo or
protein as i've described
earlier on in this
presentation
we also offer
dispensing and custom modifications of
plates within our portfolio
and finally the manufacturing and
kitting of your
either product or or
kit for your downstream application so
whether that means that you particularly
need certain plastic wares in there or
certain dispense
volumes
or even certain documentation
and
branding on your products as well these
are all things that we handle within the
cardiff manufacturing site
probably good to highlight
with the title of this site um for for
your custom
magnetic particles and how they they can
help you um
we run through a number of steps um
to help your uh you realize your custom
conjugation this does start with a
number of questions about what you're
intending to do and typically we have a
technical call with your technical lead
uh or yourselves to just for you to have
a chance to describe
what you would like
from the
custom work and then we also very openly
describe what we're capable of and what
we can deliver to yourselves so in that
early discussion can take a a week or so
and then we'll go through a period of
planning how we're going to manufacture
it in the cardiff site um
we come back to yourselves to describe
what we have planned
and then move into a proof of principle
phase where we'll make a small amount of
the material we've agreed upon in the
planning and early discussions
and then return it to yourselves for
testing or even
share with you the data which has been
generated
during that proof of principle work
it's quite common for the proof of
principle to be
multi-stepped as maybe it's an iterative
process process between our capabilities
and your realization of your product but
ultimately
we intend for that to lead to a final
product specification
and then with yourselves and with us we
will lock down the product specification
and engage with the manufacturing teams
in cardiff um specifically on how to
transfer that product into manufacture
setting that up within our electronic
resource management systems as well as
utilizing the full scale
of manufacturing uh within cardiff
this phase is typically called our
validation and verification
phase and so we'll go through a number
of challenges to your design to our
methods
for making that design um as well as
setting up say artwork
specific bottles and labels
specifications for raw materials so that
can take a number of weeks to get
through but by the time that that
process is completed we will be in the
position to manufacture your first
batches of custom products
and so
that first batch will be manufactured um
again if it's part of the validation
strategy you'll be involved with that
and we'll be involved with this custom
team as well as the quality and the
manufacturing teams on site in cardiff
but ultimately it ends up with a place
where you will have your product code to
order them your custom product again and
again um as and when you want as if it
was a normal product off of the site eva
website
uh things which we're quite proud of in
cardiff is we're always open to audits
and site visits um and in these
challenging times as well we're open to
virtual site visits and audits as well
so please talk to us if you have any
questions and queries we're happy to
happy to dig into them
we're proud of our iso 9001
accreditation and our quality quality
management system as well and we're
happy to run through that with
yourselves
um
and
also
just finally case it wasn't entirely
clear this process that we have for many
for making your your custom conjugation
it's very much a collaboration between
the two groups so we agree what's going
to be made and we share with you what is
happening at each step of the of the
process so that you can be involved and
get the product which you want at the
end of the day
so
just to
give a quick summary of where we have
been uh through this slide thank you
very much for your time um
and and for for listening in
so
sativa has three distinct magnetic b
technologies the uh maxepheros the
ciramag and the ceracilmag particles
um
they are all supported by the custom
solutions team custom services team in
cardiff in the uk so please ask any
questions
we
are happy to work with yourselves on
what is possible from magnetic particles
and your application
and it's very common that
with the simplicity of using the
magnetic properties of these particles
and how common and how uh
capable they are to bind different uh
functions and ligands onto the surface
of them we're confident that you can
improve your the street the your
laboratory workflow
to help you get more data from
your samples or from more samples over
time
so
yeah just to highlight that we can
streamline your workflow we can improve
your sample preparation within with
regards to how quick it can be you can
process your samples
you'll get higher purity as it's easier
to remove contaminants from the
your solutions
and we can reduce the number of steps
you have in your protocols in indeed
speeding up your time at the bench to
get you more data more rapidly
so thank you very much for your time
thank you for being part of this
presentation and
i look forward to taking any questions
thank you
tom thank you for that outstanding
presentation
we will now move into the live q a
portion of our presentation
as a reminder to our audience please
submit your questions via the q a box
okay tom let's we've got quite a few
questions already coming in let's start
with this question
are there limits to the scale possible
for the custom conjugations
think of that
um it's uh
it's interesting we when when we uh
discuss the custom opportunities for
these conjugations
we find a number of them align with our
current manufacturing processes
and we're quite open with any of our
discussions about what the scale is
possible so
typically
um
the the the request is for a few
milliliters
tens of milliliters
and then obviously there's a forecast
and there's a demand if this is going to
become a final product or something
which is going to be expanded to other
groups so we'll typically go from the
tens of milliliters with an eye to
scaling up to to a couple of liters of
conjugation and that all lines up with
what we currently do in cardiff and we
do we
we have a number of discussions with the
manufacturing teams with the research
and development teams to see how
appropriate your custom conjugation
would be
for
sort of that end goal to get you to the
to the scales you need to get to
and then we'll discuss inside the
project
with yourselves
what
experiments validations
may be required to get us to that
scale of conjugation with
the right quality and the right um
the the right uh
kind of uh price
for you guys so yeah thank you for that
great and thank you
and while we're talking about custom
conjugations
are the custom conjugations appropriate
for use within a regulated sector
yeah thank you again yeah it's it's a
good one um
i think
what
the manufacturing site in cardiff which
is where iron base which is where our
team is based
where we make the ceramic beads is an
iso 9001 manufacturing facility
but the quality systems which are in
place we find are appropriate for a
great many of other um regulatory
requirements um so what we actually
asked uh
to do was
the sort of the discussions with
the customers with yourselves
is to
uh
review our manufacturing processes our
quality
requirements uh to see how appropriate
they are for your
regulated area you're working or moving
into or you are already working within
and that typically
actually covers um
a site visit or in at the moment a
virtual site visit so we've done a
couple of them over the last number of
months as well so we're quite open to
having um discussions about uh
what we do how we do it and whether
that's appropriate for your product um
going
forward great
and let's just keep the ball rolling on
custom conjugations how long does it
look typical excuse me how long does it
typically take for a custom conjugation
to be completed
thanks um
so
obviously
uh no maybe this isn't obvious we are a
small team so this is quite this is this
is what we are in our custom team um but
we are supported by a
large manufacturing group and a research
and development group so
what what we typically find is when we
get the raw materials on site
um when we've confirmed what the
manufacturing process is if there's any
outstanding questions sometimes we've
received and may
i could see other questions in there so
sometimes we've received um a different
paramagnetic particle so there's some
sort of exploration and experiments to
look at the handling of that material
but i'd say once we have everything
nailed down we normally have the
conjugate made within two weeks and
shipping back to you for testing within
that amount of time so we'll share
tracking details and so on
thank you
sure and thank you
um can you help me with guidance on how
to conjugate my in-house developed
protein
yeah so
obviously there's there's lots of
considerations
um
for a
a protein and and uh sort of um
what's its stability
uh what its application and so on um
what i probably would point you towards
is there's there's quite a good um
breakdown called magbeats 101 on the
sativa website so you can google it or
we can email it to you after this
discussion but that has a good breakdown
of techniques and methods um but also
what you'll actually find is if you get
in touch with us um
give us a bit of a description about
what you can do whether there needs to
be ndas in place or all those bits
and we'll discuss with you um
things we would do in-house
and i've got to say quite a lot of those
discussions we've had over the years
have actually ended up us attempting the
conjugation for you just so you can have
an idea of what the um
the performance might be
um that's quite a a collaborative
approach and again we try and be as open
as we can um with regards to what we can
share um but also we
we
i think
certainly from my experience of working
within sativa within this group i think
we have a good idea of um
some of the the burdens to entry for uh
customers such as yourselves so we try
not to make that a financial one we try
and
get to the technical challenges as soon
as we can so i'll just say talk to your
local sativa rep there'll be a modality
specialist who will talk to me um
directly and we'll
discuss your problem in technical detail
and we'll probably end up having a
technical call um to sort of see what
the options are so there's the website
and there's contact us directly and you
can have a chat with us um on a
conference call or something thank you
great tom thanks for that information
there are several questions that came in
regarding that so you've really covered
um quite a few questions so thank you
um looks like we have time for just a
couple more let's try to squeeze maybe
two in
do you only conjugate with ceramic
family particles this is a two-parter
and are you open to conjugating our
in-house made paramagnetic particles
yep
thank you i kind of alluded to it
earlier it has happened a couple of
times um where there is a specific
particle developed by
yourselves or you have one which you
would like to
which is more appropriate for your
application um
we are open to that um
i i would say um some of the challenges
with conjugation of these magnetic
particles
is they can be quite sticky uh they they
may not be homogenous um or mono
dispersed so
i mean i i think those are some of the
real
key positives about the ceramic
particles that they're not sticky they
are mono dispersed um but but we would
be open to um
to getting your particles whether that
was a the particle you guys would like
to source and send it to us we can talk
about what concentration they need to be
in and what functionality and buffers
they are stored in or whether there's
one from a catalog you'd like us to
source for part of the conjugation or
whatever so we're open we're open to
most things uh with regards to that
but again always good to look at the
ceramic particles
they're quite they're quite good for
this sort of application
sure
thanks tom and we have time for one more
question and i'm gonna go with this one
it's come in twice can you ship custom
conjugations to the asia pacific region
yeah thank you um so
the shipping
is kind of a two-part answer so for the
custom conjugation specifically that's
with me and my team we will drop ship so
this will be um
dhl express
we will consult with our um
customs
custom support team and regulatory teams
to confirm how we can ship whether we
need to get licenses
etc etc there'll be brokers at either
end this is quite common in shipping to
asia um so
it can be quite a manual process but yes
we do it we do it regularly um it
happens also very regularly with the lyo
stable side of the business as well so
we we're very possible to do that i
would also just sort of like close that
one off is
with the custom conjugations um
when that does become a final product
like a product number you would buy from
sativa that will have all of the
regulatory uh and the shipping terms all
built into the setup of that product so
that will go through a slightly
different logistics channel um through
the site the main sativa logistics
channel and be distributed through
worldwide hubs which would include asia
as well so that one
um it
would be uh there may be some more
discussion up front but when you receive
the material it will be like ordering
anything from the site eva website
great thanks tom and i think that might
prompt some more questions and i just
want to remind our audience that you
know the questions that we're not able
to answer today and
um any questions that come in during the
on-demand period so
you know to our audience if you want to
come back and watch this on demand you
can submit questions and tom will be
able to answer them via email
so tom thank you so much for your time
today i want to thank our audience for
the for their outstanding questions tom
do you have any final comments for our
audience
um i
thank you very much for listening i
think it's a really broad subject um
we've tried to sort of pitch it as a
really broad overview of magnetic beads
and applications so if there are any
specific questions let us know
and you may find that in some of the
booths we've got as well for sort of
nucleic acid isolation or something like
that or even just come and visit us in
in the custom um and designing booth
that we've got open as well so uh yeah
hopefully speak to you later
yes and i'll piggyback on that we do
have the booths available and their
boots there are booth reps in the
booth right now that you can have
one-on-one chats video chats um and with
a live person so feel free to visit our
booths in the exhibit hall tom thank you
again for your time today i want to tell
our audience that this presentation will
be available on demand for 12 months so
please remember to share this with your
colleagues who might be interested in
today's topic and don't miss out on our
other presentations on the agenda the
agenda tab in the auditorium will
provide a full listing
so thanks again tom thank you thank you
to our audience
everyone stay safe and have a great day
bye